justement en parlant de franck dubosc je
voudrais avoir un extrait c'est quand il
y en ruine et la carrière de franck
dubosc en insinuant qu'il avait commis
des crimes atroces me regarder ça
c'était magnifique
tu t'en veux énormément parce que ce
soir là je pense que tu as fait grosse p
au fait ça tu as faites entrer l'accusé
tu veux terminer ma carrière participe à
la
[Applaudissements]
dollée situe à humilier situe à tuer
[Rires]
si tu descends c'est dans la carrière et
faire un petit séjour en prison
la brûlure de cigarette de la moquette
tout neuf à ces [ __ ]
mais derrière la brûlure il y avait un
cadavre
[Applaudissements]
qu'on avait avec à droite et comme il ya
de l'amour voilà si le jeu si et elie
j'aurais juste revoir un truc ce que je
te le met pratiquement à chaque fois
c'est pas dire men jackson annoncée à la
radio on avait fait un canular à j'adore
les canulars regardez c'est sur virgin
radio mais ça à chaque fois tu la mets
loupé lamentable
semoun qui s'y colle on appelle quelques
collages on y va le collège lazare il
serait à lyon à lyon merci
oui bonjour c'est à 4,8
[Musique]
j'adorais
bonjour
tient pas la
[Applaudissements]
cible à son groupe pierre palace c'est
ça qui nous faisait rire sur les petites
annonces aussi c'est magique regardez
les bêtises et ont changé les noms à
chaque fois mais sur ces morts derrière
c'est exceptionnel mais enfin jumeaux
patients pour ça et une petite annonce
même vous feriez un prime spécial ou un
truc comme ça même sur canal plus ce
serait magnifique après c'est toi le
patron
non mais je peux proposer je peux pas
trouver connaît déjà
quelques connexions mais je crains qu'un
prime sur canal de petites annonces
inédites avec des anciennes et des
nouvelles a franchement ok si j'étais
producteur jeffrey dacquois sait compter
que l'animateur
mais j'ai quand même envie de revoir je
suis obligée de te le mettre je suis la
remettre au hasard
j'oubliais à chaque fois que tu bluffes
sommités de la m
elie semoun en place d'abord un cédez
jamais traité le frère de encore mais ça
va être votre style et lyon j'adore mais
moi je le suis tous les jours je connais
beaucoup mieux son actu que vous quand
vous le suivez tous les jours c'est à
dire c'est bon pour vous qu'il a appelé
la police et l'armée
non c'est vrai que je le suis sur
instagram donc je sais tout ce qu'il
fait à oui c'est vrai et 1 minute et le
spectacle vous savez je suis qu ennemi
vous aimez les hommes drôle chez qui
disent à peu de bottiers
c'est vrai mais d'abord je vais gérer
bernard on m'a dit les hommes drôle
de qualité mais on peut regarder ça
effectivement
j'ai pu regarder déshabille
pas non plus aller jouer
à la démo non plus il voterait pas
valérie perbet arrêté qu'est ce qui se
passe avec valérie pécresse ce soir si
je
n'exagère pas valérie pécresse et 6
passes mais aucun mais il me dit je ne
voudrais pas valérie pécresse c'est une
provocation bah oui les relations ça
commence comme ça
peut-être qu'il va voter j'essaye de
dire comme lui
oui moi j'en peux plus des violences
si rome était l'homme et le clip pour
mot kitsch mais couple
[Applaudissements]